[Music]
my name is Joel Conklin I'm a product
manager for Earth engine Earth engines
the petabyte scale processing platform
for geospatial data Google used by a
wide range of industries we've been
developing it over the last 10 years and
I'm excited to tell you a little bit
about it and show you a few demos
it'll illustrate some of what it can do
so when we think about Earth engine we
think about two things one is it's a
massive data catalog with open data from
satellite imagery and many others and a
computation platform where you can
analyze that data in a variety of
different ways to meet your news cases
we see users from agriculture industry
forestry industry oil and gas natural
resources and a wide variety of others
and we'll go through a use case here in
a second we'll do that through the lens
of an agriculture use case so imagine
you're working in a company you have a
customer who's a farmer in Arizona he
wants to know how his agricultural
fields are doing maybe he's farming corn
wheat soy something like that and we're
gonna go through a use case that shows
how that works in north engine I
mentioned the earth engine data catalog
it's about 500 data sets of geospatial
data 30 petabytes and growing with a
wide range of data types from climate
and weather data imagery and radar data
geophysical socio-economic air quality
data and many more you can bring your
own data to earth engine as well so if
you're doing analysis where you like
open data and your own data that's easy
to do and what that does is it lets you
get started faster
so instead of figuring out what data you
need where do you find it how do you
download it how do you pre process it
what you can do with Earth engine is
just identify that data in the catalog
and start start your work start your
hypothesis and so I'm gonna go to a demo
right now which will show us a little
bit about how that works so here with
five lines of code there in the middle
of the screen
we've done some Bolton data in for
analysis the first line identified as
the data set second line says you know
what date do we want to look at here on
the third line we're doing some
visualization parameters adding it to
the map and telling it what part of the
map to to show I hit run and you can see
this data set so this is Landsat 8 it's
a satellite imagery program run by the
US government it covers the globe every
16 days we've asked it for one day and
you can see the path of the satellite
from over the course that day
so we haven't asked much of our engine
yet in terms of computation but when you
do start to do computation you often
start in the code editor what we call
the code editor and here at the top in
the middle is where you write your
script right above that there's a Run
button which I use just now which gives
you the ability to run calculations in
our engine and then you can look at your
results on top of the map either here at
the bottom or if you click somewhere on
the map you can see the results in the
top right you also have access to all of
your scripts all of your data and
documentation about how to use our
engine in the top left panel there in
addition to the code editor environment
we also have programming api's you can
use those programming api's in Jupiter
collab notebooks environments like that
or pull data into your DCP workflows
with ApS as well I'm going to go through
a series of nut of additional demos here
where we'll start to answer that
question for the farmer how are my
fields doing this year so the first
thing I'll do is show you what it looks
like when you pull in 16 days of data
which should give us pretty full
coverage of the United States and the
whole globe so that's that's given a
Landsat satellite time to cover the
entire globe as a you know someone who's
working to answer questions for a farmer
you might care about a longer time
series than that so I'll make this a
six-month time series and you can hit
run there and so again with relatively
few lines of code not that much work to
do you're pulling in data from you know
six months worth of Landsat hundreds of
gigabytes of data is at your fingertips
and lanced out you know catalog itself
goes back 30 or 40 years so you can go
away way farther back in history than
that so we've also got this median value
here which is basically looking at over
six months you've got 12 images for each
part of the each part of the planet it's
looking at the median value for each of
the bands
in that image it turns out that clouds
are highly reflective so if you want to
find clouds you change medium to Max and
once that comes up you'll see that there
are clouds almost everywhere over the
United States at some point during that
six-month period a quick and easy way to
mask out clouds which is a more common
thing to do as you change that median to
a min and run matte and you've got a
decent cloud free mosaic of the United
States or anywhere in the globe again
you know pretty simple and easy to do in
Earth engine not that much work
in the agricultural space you care how
well is your vegetation doing how
healthy is your vegetation and one
common way of doing that is with the
normalized difference vegetation index
or NDVI it's a pretty simple calculation
we start with the same code that we had
before to bring that imagery in define a
function a 10 DB I use existing earth
engine operators to do that calculation
it's you know one band - another divided
by one band plus another add the results
to the image that you're working on and
then here you map that across all the
imagery and you're in your collection
define the palette add it to the map you
know pick what part of the map you want
to show and in this case I'm going to
show part of Arizona where there's some
agricultural fields and hit run and
that'll start pulling in and dbi data on
top of some imagery data
so what that NDB eye is showing as you
get higher values that goes to darker
green and those dark green values read
register for lots of where areas where
there's lots of hesitation you can also
in move the transparency sliders up and
down to get a sense of what's behind
that imagery you can toggle the layers
on and off so a variety of things you
can do to sort of inspect the data with
a few more lines of code we can do a lot
more and here we're again starting with
that same basic code that we had in the
previous example adding a little bit of
UI on top of that in this case we're
adding a map and a label on one side and
not gonna label on the other side
linking those two maps with a function
called linker and adding a split panel
on top of that so with a few more lines
of code now you're able to go into Earth
engine and scroll back and forth and see
you know NDVI and how that relates to
the imagery underneath so a pretty
useful tool for analyzing that data and
again as a you know a farmer you might
want to care you might care a lot about
how that data is changing over time so
in this code I've added a another panel
at the bottom with this this code here
and added a series chart to that panel
and so when I click on the map that's
going to show me the NDVI over time with
you know that 0 to 1 range for NDVI is
bounded and you can see that generally
speaking for this farmer overall in 2018
the NDVI looks pretty good in july 18th
it looks like that it was probably a
cloud over there over the over the farm
so that's why that's showing us a low
number the last demo I have here is
going to run a comparison just adding
another time series chart running
comparison between 2017 and 2018
so as that comes up we'll have NDVI for
2017 on the left-hand side NDVI for 2018
on the right-hand side and we'll start
to see comparisons between the two
datasets and that'll start to give us an
answer of how healthy are the fields how
much vegetation is on those fields one
year versus another and so again
clicking on that same roughly that same
spot and looking at the results we can
see that the NDVI in 2018 at the bottom
here was higher for most of the year
than it was in 2017 so this is all using
data center public catalog you can bring
in your own data into this as well and
using components that are easily
available in Earth engine to let you
inspect that data in various ways so
going back into the slides so we've
spent a lot of time a few minutes in the
code editor which is where we do
interactive analysis we've started to
get a simple answer for one farmer if
you want to do that at scale that's
where you start using Earth engines
batch capability so that allows you to
scale globally say you've got thousands
of farmers that you're serving around
the world
it lets you automate runs it lets you
basically take advantage of Earth
engines parallel computing architecture
and on the right here we've got an
example from not the agriculture space
but from work that we did with the
European jrc joint research center where
they wanted to track surface water over
the course of 30 years you know where
surface water had been change over 30
years ended up being 10 million hours of
computation we put 10,000 CPUs against
it which will have a computation to
finish in less than 2 days so you know
when you really want to run a big job
orthe engine can can help with that
and if you want to build our engine
analysis into an app into a webpage into
a mobile app engine API is allow you to
do that it gives your users the ability
to customize their data customize their
the answers that they want and you know
basically get a lot of the value and
power of Earth engine without writing
code
code themselves so that's a another
feature where things can help you scale
your analysis have greater impact with
your analysis help it reach more and
more of your users in a way that makes
sense so this my last slide if you are
interested in earth engine you think you
might be able to help you solve some of
your problems faster you can go to earth
engine Google com
click Sign Up and Earth engine is free
to evaluate and you can start kicking
the tires start using the code editor
the API is whatever makes sense to you
and take it from there that's all I have
thank you very much for your attention I
appreciate you listening and yeah thanks
for coming
[Music]